first of all I was watching you on tiger
belly with Bobby and it was fantastic
you guys were amazing but you you told
this story and this resonated so much it
was about like the the nerves and
anxiety you had on the Irishman now I
haven't done the Irishman or but but
there is something about like you sold
out Madison Square Garden a million
[__] times like you've done Arenas
around the world you're the highest
selling com and you walk into a movie
set and all that just goes away goes
away man yeah so this is something I'm
not used to doing which is acting you
know I do stand up pretty much you know
every night or trying to work on stuff
so now I'm in a scene with peshi
dairo and scorsi coming out of nowhere I
don't even know where this guy is at in
on set and uh it's nerve-wracking it's
it's you know I I I had a lot of anxiety
doing like pes's wife was he was doing a
thing that was like improvy and was kind
of annoying peshy and pes's wife was
like keep doing it so got to like
actively piss off Joe peshi cuz his wife
is saying it's a good idea but I'm
pissing off Joe peshi it's like a crazy
thing but it's this weird thing that I
think is like I wonder if it's only in
us where we can feel like the top of the
world in our industry and it means
nothing the second we are in Hollywood
yeah and they kind of treat you as if it
means nothing yeah it doesn't mean
doesn't mean anything like did did did
the grips and stuff the people who work
on this on the movie know they know you
and you're like the biggest star right
see I never even think anybody knows me
I swear to God
it's just I but I get what he's saying
yeah goad go yeah I mean like I you know
every time I put tickets on sale I ask
myself is
anybody
coming so um I'll give you an example I
uh I did this voice over in Super Mario
Brothers I was Spike I have two kids six
and four we're at Universal Studios by
the way I feel like I I have to come to
my come to the right here too because of
the
cologne I'm g walk you over here every
time I feel War pie you smell it a
cartoon the Italians are just drawn to
it Tom
for so we're at Universal Studios there
is a Super Mario store so I so said kids
come on in let's go see Daddy's
character they got every character on
the wall but mine Spike so that's kind
of sums up my career I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
people I have fans but I'm not like
widely known
funny you think that so F think that
yeah I don't believe that at all the way
I feel but I know it's the way you feel
and I felt that like I felt that in in
films or in Hollywood in general and I
think it's just cuz they care so little
about standup like the Hollywood Matrix
thinks it's like this weird like
Sideshow and we walk in and we're like
wait a minut no no no we're this is the
coolest thing and we're the best at it
and they're like that's great here's
your lines here's your side there's your
trailer you're sharing with three other
guys there's one bathroom yeah and
you're like I TR on a bus everywhere I
go like we don't give a [__] yeah it it
doesn't translate over to like you're
say TV and film I I you know but it's
expected do we welcome do the standups
welcome the actors to our you know like
you always hear this guy that's going to
do standup and but he was something else
prior and you do we go oh yeah you know
you're part of a family I do we do that
or we think that your career is
struggling yeah I was doing it again oh
okay yeah good I just why is stand
always the default to somebody else's
other career it's not it's not like
we're going into professional
football it's either stand up or
DJ football you know what you're doing
you're signing up at prize picks use a
promo code Schultz and they will match
your initial deposit up to $100 that
means you put in a 100 you get a 100 for
free that's all you got to do price.com
promo code Schultz let's get back to the
show it's I saw Madonna once at the uh
she was at the comedy cell she just
sitting down at a table and people
couldn't even talk to one another every
conversation was like this yeah so
totally we we we we'll definitely go out
to the nobody was listening at all
somebody said that about hanging out
with Eddie Murphy everything just stops
and you just everyone's looking at Eddie
yeah was that what uh was that with was
dairo kind of was that was that like
being around dairo like the the
energy I I haven't been in a social
environment with him so I don't know how
work socially and he's so unassuming
when he's out and about that you you
don't even really know it's it's him you
know sometimes I didn't even know it was
him when we did the table read I didn't
even recognize him he came in like a
little hat yeah he had a beard and I
wouldn't have recognize him on the
street or if he in a restaurant unless
somebody told me yeah but um no I didn't
I didn't have that with him on set I
felt like on set it was like a work
environment yeah and everybody was kind
of like in our own little bubble is he
funny at all like in between takes and
that kind of [__] like it would he bust
your balls a little bit nothing no was
you trying to make them laugh uh I'm not
trying to make anybody laugh no I'm not
I'm not when I'm on doing a movie that's
all I'm concerned about is I got to
memorize these lines no Small Talk No
not not a lot of that he he would like
go go to his chair so funny after the
scene I would go to my chair and he
would have like you know a bunch of
papers and whatnot and be on the phone
he'd be talking I go this guy opening up
another
[Laughter]
nobo this is your life's work this is
The Pinacle of your career this guy's
flipping through the [__] times yeah
he's looking at the expense reports so I
I uh I didn't know there wasn't that
there wasn't that relationship he's he's
a quiet guy yeah he's a quiet guy and
he's kind of to himself and he doesn't
talk a lot if you talk to him he he'll
engage but it's not like we cut and I'm
like what's going where you going
tonight there's none of that he's like
I'm
80 get some rest my go tonight what
about peshy was peshy a little bit uh
peshy um he was very cordial and hey you
know welcome to the set nice and then he
called me into his dressing room
afterwards we we we spoke in there he he
was a lot more outgoing yeah and we we
golfed together uh back in La so he he's
definitely more of a kind of a outgoing
guy he lived with my uh grandparents
weirdly for like a year really when he
was like a teenager it in like Montclair
New Jersey I think he grew up out there
in like in in
Montclair how are your grandar he was
friends with my uncle and I think that I
don't know he like needed a place to
stay or some [__] and ended up just kind
of like living with the grandparents and
my uncle for a little while whoa yeah
randomly that's crazy yeah and then just
goes and becomes one of the most iconic
actors ever yeah but yeah they were just
like sipping robot husing for a
summer
I think back in the day robotussin had
like the uh what is it called uh the
amphetamines yeah it had like
aetam so you could get kind of like high
on it how do you know that this guy
knows everything he knows how to sell a
fake Porche
guy do the movie sets ever get
monotonous like like is it are you
annoyed being on the set of a movie it's
not it was not the most fun experience
for me what what bothers you about it it
you know doing standup you know it's
it's like can't compare it you can't
compare it it's boring compared to stand
up but you still want to do it like I
understand I imagine where you're coming
from which is like your whole life
you're watching movies and you're seeing
these things come to life and you're
like I have the opportunity to do it
with the greatest actors ever and also
storytelling which is what you know we
do in comedy the the Pinnacle of
Storytelling in my opinion is through
film like you actually get to [__]
see it but while you're making it but
what's more satisfying when it's done
when you're watching it back that's
where you get the satisfaction so so you
got to kind of keep your eye on the on
the prize going okay you got to kind of
go through all this and at the end of
this the end product is what you're kind
of hoping it turns out fabulous is that
more satisfying than watching one of
your specials when it's done and edited
and all that uh I even don't even like
watching the specials I like the process
of doing standup comedy I don't
necessarily like to watch the end
product on a special is it hard like
doing jokes and everybody on set can't
laugh cuz it [__] up the take mhm did
you get used to like doing jokes to
silence that was a big big problem for
me still is uh so you would do this uh
scene right as a comedian they yell cut
and you're like all where's the standing
over we're moving on moving on you know
it's there's no there's no feedback no
feedback although doing this new show I
Chuck Lori and Nick Bai are very good of
about
laughing was bookie on Max by the way
yeah yeah some uh some directors know
what Like Comics need and they'll kind
of lean in a little bit more to it
because we do need because there's
moments when I came to the screening of
uh of the movie about my father right
and and there's moments where you're
doing like you're you're you're being
big like the bird thing where the act
out you're doing and it was like I'm
imagining you doing that on set and
everybody's told to be quiet and then
they're going cut and I'm imagining what
I would feel in that moment like I'm
being big and I'm trying to be funny
feel this
big like oh let me see if I could like
reach out here and do something funny or
whatever and you do that and it cut and
then it's like that's like takes out the
times bro silence in an act out is just
brutal an act out on what you're hoping
they yell cut and everybody like just
holding it in but when you don't hear it
even after the cut you're like that died
yeah yeah what was what was the biggest
bomb you felt on set that one that 100%
yeah that was definite and because can
you describe the scene for for people
watching so I'm like uh this is I'm
walking around me and dairo on just them
in the room in a bedroom and we're
talking about my wife's side of the
family and I think the line was
something like yeah and they're they're
walking around like like birds I'm like
fu
but I I'm even watching it I go I don't
think that's that funny even I said as I
I was watching I go no wonder I didn't
get a laugh that
suck but in the room is Just The Two Of
so it's him and dairo and he's going for
it and you don't know in the moment is
like is dairo like going this is the
funniest [__] I've ever seen is he
egging you on like or is he going I
think he was even going what are you
doing wait why why why why I just cuz
you saw
[Laughter]
it I'm sure you were sitting in your
seat going what the [__] is that so yeah
no I I don't know it it was a learning
experience that movie you got to say
your Eddie Murphy one oh dude I bombed
so big in front of Eddie Eddie's the
reason I did stand up so and I had three
lines in this movie and I have like one
with Eddie and I line I [__] up seven
times in a row and it's not a scene
where there's like six people here and a
few cameras it's in a nightclub with
minimum 100 naked strippers dancing
around okay and then people fake tipping
the strippers whatever it's Jonah Hill
Eddie Murphy and I got to say a line and
I don't even know what the [__] line
is to be honest with you even to this
day I've like I blacked it out PTSD but
it's something like yeah you know he was
doing coke because he had it all over
the strip in Las Vegas and I go you know
he's on a strip in v a [__] you know
he's on a and I do five in a row and I
finally get it and I'm like yeah you
know he's doing Co do striping Las Vegas
and then Eddie he supposed to like kind
of play with me he goes
yeah bro pin drop nothing okay I'm
sitting there and I'm just like well
this is everything I've ever dreamed for
in my entire life every there for
nothing it's I'm sitting there I'm like
[__] man I just [__] up my moment cuz
that day that morning I'm going in going
I'm going to kill this line anded he's
going to go we should go back out on
tour like it's it's over yeah literally
the next scene you know Filipe Esparza
hilarious comic Felipe comes out he has
a line right and he comes in and his
line is uh hey man I got you these
things this the edible edible
arrangements right he comes in he goes I
got these things these Edible
Arrangements Eddie's supposed to respond
to him he stops the scene he goes stop
he looks at Fel he goes you're [__]
hilarious
it stops production he goes you're
hilarious that was amazing let's do that
again and you're there watching us I'm
sitting there watching faking tip
strippers and he's doing his mind and
Eddie's like you got to do that
again just one tear comes down bro so
you were hoping that he would have said
that to you of course are you kidding me
so did you have any banter with him
coming into the scene off no I was like
so nervous to even like I just you know
hold him to such high regard that I
didn't I didn't want to make him feel
uncomfortable yeah yeah in any way you
have so many scenes with dairo that
doesn't go well in your eyes are you
scared to improv with them after uh yeah
your confidence a little shot I think
you know coming off a coming off a a
physical bit in a movie and they get
nothing the next scene we're like I just
stick it to the
script stop improvising oh that was that
was a choice you made at one like you
know in the moment comic
can you expl can you explain the idea of
like of making a choice in acting
because I think that's something a lot
of people don't get you get a script but
it doesn't tell you physically what else
to do like there's a story you told
about the flicking the pin on on pes's
yeah yeah yeah and and doesn't tell you
to do it in the script it doesn't tell
you but you just you know you you start
doing stuff in a scene that might not be
written in the script the problem is if
you do not commit and this is this is
true to standup comedy and and I know
this because I could tell if I don't
commit to a bit it's it's a dead in the
water same thing with acting if you do
not commit 100% to what you're doing it
comes off as false fake people see right
through it okay and I believe when I was
walking around that bedroom like a bird
it wasn't 100 commit 100% commitment for
me can you show us what that would look
like 100% commitment oh God almost like
I even even just doing it like if you
want me to get
physical see I didn't get that I see it
I see it I didn't even I just nobody did
that and nobody did that that's what I
was looking for in the scene see I just
started to do a little of it and I'm
getting laugh there it was it wasn't as
committed and and and it shows it bleeds
right through the film you saw it I was
looking at it in the in the movie
theater going it's so funny
not
funny it was it was not it was notl in
your own
movie I'm just telling you guy stinks
sucks who is this
guy yeah for me did they yell cut mid
like like tell me what happens in the
scene no I think I'm doing I think I'm
doing that even longer you know trying
to make something happen there's no way
to cut around it cuz you you could have
cut it out it's your movie yeah yeah but
even like that needed to be in there
because you know I go like it's you know
is that's the best we got I
mean you you have you have grander ideas
in your head of how something is going
to go like you and Eddie Murphy you
thought that was going to be oh this is
going to be an amazing scene and when it
doesn't go as amazing as you'd like it
to go it's a a learning experience and B
is you know it's very it's very
disappointing but I took all those
experiences from that movie and built
upon it for the next project that movie
I had excruciate I'm not making excuses
I'm just saying what was going on in my
head yeah I had excruciating sciatic
pain ripping down my right leg right
from the bird thing no no just from life
oh from from stress and and back issues
and I was in Alabama right away from my
family away from my kids for 9 weeks and
I was was contemplating what am I doing
here yeah yeah yeah yeah I have two kids
yeah I'm doing a movie this is fantastic
but I felt like I was disappointing
almost my family yeah two months yeah
yeah it's it's a long that was a long
time so so not to say that I wasn't 100%
committed but externally I I I wasn't in
a good place I was down the road for
standup every night you know I crushed
so I'm away from my family but I know
what I just did movie you don't know I
also think that people don't realize
like and again I'm not trying to count
her Pockets here but when when someone
like you does a movie when someone like
Kevin Hart does a movie often times
they're losing money they have to stop
touring hoping that maybe this movie it
absolutely explodes and you get a piece
of it I obviously I don't know what the
financials are right there but like I
don't think people realize that I think
people just go oh movies everybody makes
$20 million a movie and that's just what
it is it's a labor of love until you're
yeah George cler absolutely that was um
I basically did the movie for for free
yeah it was it was a free in comparison
to what I make doing standup comedy this
this was like but you want to brought in
your audience you know sometimes you
want to like challenge yourself like oh
let's see what a movie feels like let's
see what a TV show feels like you kind
of got to get out of your what do you
think with the TV show like in terms of
scheduling and lifestyle easier than the
film for me it was because was in LA
yeah it was with Chuck Lori Chuck Lori
maybe give some background on like what
he's done in television Two and a Half
Men big Bank der young Sheldon mom he
don't need to work anymore yeah no need
to work anymore Kaminsky method so he he
was a joy to work with and working with
someone like that who's got north of a
thousand episodes of TV under the belt
and they're all successful I felt a lot
more comfortable with him in that
environment we were in Los Angeles he
knows what he wants he's he's quick you
know the whole thing about these TV INF
like he waiting around this was this
this was like this was really quick yeah
I mean this was like 9 10h hour days
which is for for that type of stuff is
short short days so I had a really
totally different experience doing
bookie than I did the the movie not not
not the poooo of the movie but the who
else is in bookie uh Omar dorsy plays my
my my muscle uh uh Andrea Anders is in
it plays my wife uh Vanessa fito who my
sister does your
wife get to choose who your wife is or
have a say no uh we ran into a little
issue when I did a pilot six years ago
for NBC remember that pilot and Vanessa
leche was going to play my wife and my
wife all of a sudden wanted to get into
acting because I could do it could do
it so she had like a there was a little
kind of think it was some jealousy or
you think little bit little a little bit
not not necessarily I just think that's
kind of hard to swallow sometimes that
you're your husband is going to have a
wife on set there might be a kissing
scene it's you know I'm I don't blame
her but uh and and she's she's fabulous
I mean just just she's so easygoing but
that one little that was like a little
like yeah I want to do it I I I want to
try try acting and that was like how'
you how' you work that out I said you
ain't doing
that so uh what was her reaction no you
know she got over it I think it was just
a small speed bump in in the in the road
and you know it's it was it was fine but
other than that she's been you know
since then I've had a couple wives in in
in shows and she's doesn't doesn't care
anymore so your wife on this show is
just she's ey yeah yeah that's if your
wife doesn't get insecure you're like
did we hire the right
one should we go a little what are we
doing
here you know what we ended up becoming
good friends with Vanessa and Andrew all
these the wives I've had in these films
yeah Leslie bib about my father we've
we've become like Fast Friends with uh
with their family so it's it's been
great